le programme singe mea est terminé notre
cible était une usine d'armes chimique
au
vol les Américains viennentici sans
aucune conséquence on va retourner leur
machine de guerre Contrex réveillez le
est en mouvement il est grand temps que
les Américains goû à la terreur qu'ils
on construite
secr leing a été activé hors de contrôle
nous avons vu ce qu'Abraham et ce lzard
ont fait à Washington T ou tard il
atteindra son point de rupture Lee est
Arsenal ambulant il faut vous assurer
qu'il nte pas
Chicago
jele nous Avre
Washington devons combattre cette chose
avec une arme
appropriée enyons
le
St arrête on peut vraiment l'aider
ok est en sa possession il y a un
dispositif nucléaire attaché au évacuer
la ville
immédiatement